Static data is not all that useful,
I know.
Luckily, you have this content provider
that has the exact data we need.
Let's put these things together.
But wait, we took all this effort and
sunshine to not run queries
on the main thread.
AsyncTasks, IntentServices, Loaders,
and SyncAdapters were all used.
What can we do here, or
is there even a problem?
Let's go back to when we added our
app widget provider to the manifest.
The app widget provider class is
actually a thin wrapper around
one of the basic types of components
on Android, a broadcast receiver.
Broadcast receiver is a short lived
component that receives broadcasts
from other components, or other apps,
through its onReceive method.
App widget provider harnesses
the broadcast sent by the Android system
provides us with a simpler to use
onUpdate() method among other things.
Turns out the onReceive() method and
hence our onUpdate() method
get called on the UI thread.
Doing anything that might take a while,
is probably not a good idea.
A very common pattern, one you need to
do more work in response to a broadcast,
is the broadcast receiver starting
an Intent Service, do to heavy lifting.
Intent Services are great for
this kind of work because the On Handle
Intent, runs on a Background Thread.
And the service is automatically
stopped once done.
No need to keep the service around
when there's nothing to do.
So we'll write an intense service that
does everything our onUpdate method did
and change our onUpdate
to CallStartService.
Now, we can use the same technique we
used elsewhere to retrieve data from our
content provider,
query to retrieve our data,
then extract the information we need.
So now, we can see our app widget
provider is calling our intent service.
Our IntentService is then querying for
the data and getting a response back.
As our AppWidgetProvider is
a broadcast receiver at its core,
our SyncAdapter could send
a data changed broadcast
to our AppWidgetProvider to update the
widgets exactly when we have new data.
We'll add a new constant
to our SyncAdapter.
Then use that constant as the action for
the broadcast we send out.
Then we'll update our manifest entry for
the app widget provider to
receive the new action.
Finally to actually handle our message,
we override the onReceive method
to look for our action and start the
Intent Service to update the widgets.